twenty thousand dollars thirty thousand
one hundred forty thousand dollars is
life dependent on me who is this guy
even sharing the same bed with so the
way you stop a modern day scammer is to
expose him
through journalism and the hunt for him
was on he has his magnetism just by
himself he's a really really smart and
cunning guy cecilia is the whistleblower
in the buzzy true crime documentary
streaming now on netflix it's an expose
on simon levi who created a fake life of
luxury to hustle millions from women he
met on tinder
that's when police tell me
the man i loved was never real
everything's alive how did the netflix
documentary come to be for you it was
kind of like growing from norway now and
everywhere else and then we got we just
got approached saying that this is going
to be made so we had an even more
fighting spirit at one point he was the
love of your life now that there's this
renewed attention on your story how do
you feel it feels really weird because
it happened like four years ago you know
kind of painful but really nice just to
see the response from everyone when you
think back
now who is simon to you oh god he's
nothing
as what we've been saying he's dead he
said he has threats against him in the
film cecilia is one of three women who
team up with a group of finnish
journalists to take simon down we needed
to get paid back we had one chance
to swindle the tindler swindler watching
you guys when you got to israel i was
really nervous i was really nervous when
you go to his childhood home and in fact
in that scene you confront uh someone
who says is his mother i was curious you
know did you guys feel in that moment
she was telling the truth or did you
feel like maybe she was covering up the
story too because uh they are speaking
in hebrew it took a few moments to
understand that this is simon's mother
we first thought that this was a
neighbor walking up the stairs and then
realized that this is actually his
mother i just believed
her story and that scene feels
insane just walking up there knocking on
doors
actually seeing a letter in the door
which is for him and then seeing his
sister and his mother feels
like the most exciting moment
like
during my career to this day cecilia is
still paying down her debts i put my own
life you know like economic life right
um completely destroyed because i
totally believe that it was a crisis
that we were in i am bankrupt here in
the uk now but my creditors in norway
won't allow it so that's why i'm still
struggling i destroyed my life in two
countries you have no idea my enemy is
trying to simon simon simon simon listen
to me i know i know a lot of people are
making fun of it on social media that my
enemies are off to me
so what does justice from simon look
like to you
i just really really want more questions
regarding why the police have never
prosecuted him in europe i know you're a
hopeless romantic i you know in the
documentary you said you're still online
dating have you found anyone you have
you met anyone yet are you still on the
apps
i maybe maybe i'll find someone
i'm trying to try to keep it a bit more
private it might have it's a it's it's a
bit more serious dating if you were to
cast someone to play you in a possible
movie who would that be i would pick
yeah jennifer lawrence that would be
is daniel day-lewis still doing acting
actually i don't know but he he should
come out of retirement for this story
perhaps this guy unceased i'm sorry and
could have done a good uh
job okay
see now we got to manifest this who
would you want to play you
it's just margot robbie it's margot
robbie you can find a bit of everything
on tinder but one little swipe
can change your life now the story
doesn't end there though today there is
a wild new twist a source tells e.t that
simon is trying to break into the
entertainment business he signed with a
talent manager in hopes of projects like
a book dating show and dating podcast
e.t received this statement from his
hollywood manager gina rodriguez she
writes i was intrigued with the netflix
story i saw the world's greatest
salesman but it left me with a lot of
unanswered questions and was very biased
i believe there are two sides to every
story and everyone should have the
chance to tell their side well sounds
like at least he'll be making his own
money now